I feel badass
yeah cuz we are badass right now there's
no badass but I've never driven before I
don't know if I can do it versus life is
in our hands okay got to step onto the
streets man let's just catch up to him
daddy demand we'll take care of the rest
all right buckle up we're about to get
nuts
I got dry-roasted but the only I've got
you Hal howls yeah hey yeah yeah yeah
you ever see that bet the Jamie Foxx
special I might need security you ever
see that what do you think Doug whoa
whoa whoa whoa I got the flash player I
got the flag
hi
oh my buddies hey where'd you get that
card check it out no don't
this is that dude is trying to kill him
but we made it everybody got plunger
yeah well you know when you gotta go
glazier behind the wheel things tend to
go on budget hey what's she doing I
don't know
I'm Jamie Foxx and he's down for ya give
up well I'm gonna shoot off the tear gas
here for you okay to fire I know I'm
going to okay very windy up here yes I
know
we'll get snacks later
damnit
keep you steady in here dude come on man
I'm a first-time driver I'm like a
student driver basically you're doing a
great job okay yeah thanks man you're a
damn oh here take this
ooh I like that Adam ders needs you he
saved your girl catcher makes your call
at that man
[Music]
yourselves
folder browser
you